[Music]
so the year
is 2020 and we can all agree that we've
been
through a lot it's been a couple years
this is one year
it doesn't matter at all i didn't think
that could happen i thought 2016 was
like oh that year was
it was pretty shitty but 2020 is like
yeah
i don't know about you guys but i'm
loving this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but you can't even travel you can't do
anything i just traveled
where'd you go i went to new jersey all
right
right that's true i want to go see
vinnie joey
we all have to remember when we're
feeling like this year is [ __ ] we have
to remember wait no no but it's not
for me y'all had it terrible it's
inspiring but for me
maybe it's a matter of perspective then
maybe
for example this this article
oh it's true and and you've been doing
like the cold like waterfall
stuff too you're just picking up a lot
of hobbies so for this texas couple here
uh robert and janice beacham they have
gone through
a lot they uh have been married for 46
years
very sweet couple is it like they've
been through a lot of struggles
struggles yes bam so oh wait hold on
wait a year was that what's the math 46
years
how many years looking at you because
you're good at math with what when did
they get mine is 20 20.
how old are they oh right now oh [ __ ]
when did they get married
like 74 1974. oh bam
here oh [ __ ] my bad dude okay i saw that
that's like because like these things
are kind of sharp too are you all right
yeah let me see
and then i got a little little scratch
mark my there 46 years
but it's not funny you know oh yeah 46
years of love
true yeah these guys have been married
for 46 years and they've had
one hell of a year so to start things
off
they both had coronavirus oof uh but
they survived
they survived and then she's positive
she has cancer
oh okay and had to go through chemo and
survived
that's positive positive she got corona
and then got cancer
or she that's just she had both she had
cancer and then and they
all yeah because like she's at risk for
being the death
yeah people that already have a
pre-existing condition all right
that's true that's true and then yeah he
had a few operations before too i
actually don't remember all the time
ahead
uh what he had but like they've they've
had certain ailments throughout the
years he's got teeth
they're up there in the age but
the craziest thing is that when he got
when he got diagnosed with coronavirus
she was prepping to go to
through chemotherapy wow so he got it
first
she got it first she gave it to her we
don't know how she got it she
she might have gone like does anyone
know where they get that you know she
probably kissed it into her mouth
perhaps maybe maybe but the creature
poured it right into
her body someone coughed on his sandwich
he took a bite of the sandwich she got
the corona and then he kissed her
that's what happened exactly facts
shouldn't have ate that pastrami buddy
[Laughter]
ain't that pastrami pastrami's good uh
but yeah so
the craziest part about this is that
they both had to go through their own
journey so when you have one of them
yeah by themselves one through going
through chemotherapy and one going
through coronavirus
and he had a very extreme case of it
like in terms of the symptoms you know
some people don't get symptoms
so he had a lot of symptoms and he was
isolated in the hospital
in the same hospital she was in a
different ward
going through chemotherapy and wasn't
that crazy because what i was hoping is
they had
separate like just holding hands yeah
they were holding hands through the
the thing incubators
they couldn't though because he has
chronovirus so it's a different room
it's a different unit it has to be
isolated corona unit
cancer unit do we know what type of
cancer sushi
yeah let me go read this real quick you
guys ever see those
uh on instagram you if you follow a meme
page they usually have like a
a hot girl and then the caption says
would you risk corona for her
oh but then i just thought of something
it'll be a nice pastrami sandwich and
the caption says
would you risk corona for this
oh my god get corona baby it's her
second round of breast cancer
and she was overwhelmed she was also
diagnosed with ovarian cancer too
oh so she's going through chemotherapy
for those things while robert is going
through coronavirus diagnosis and
whatnot
so this is currently happening uh they
beat it it's a habit it's a happy story
yeah
so that's a positive thing a little
she's a professional coaster
it is a roller coaster and then check it
this is the the cool part and this is
the car i wanted to share
so the the the robert's doctor who was
treating his chronovirus symptoms
he caught wind of the fact that janice
was also in the hospital for for chemo
and all these
things so he uh was basically working
with
the hospital and like you know all the
caregivers
between the two of them to bring them
home and figure out a way and then they
don't really go into detail how this
happened
but they figured out a way to attend to
their needs by bringing them home
and and uh they were diagnosed in march
april i think 19th was their
wedding anniversary and they had they
were like at the height of the [ __ ]
quarantines
we're gonna get you guys home so you
guys can experience your anniversary
46th year anniversary
while they were you know dealing with
coronavirus is that how she got
coronavirus central i don't know yeah
they kind of skipped around something
you should have stayed in the hospital
you know what the cure for corona is
then right
love love love healed them and it's a
cure for cancer
all that [ __ ] that's what they're saying
they were like [ __ ] hating each other
for 46 years
and then they brought them together
they're like hate cures hey that's what
you need you need anger you need hate
you need arguments oh there's a lot of
yeah plenty of that in the world yeah
easy to come by
it has to be from your your significant
other oh there's a lot
maybe it's different it's different yeah
so true
but yeah so that's what they're saying
they're saying like their love and the
fact that they were able to be together
in this
like trying time they you know really
helped them uh
i think like spiritually and and and and
and getting better and staying positive
in this time so
i don't know i just thought it was a
really cute story this is a cute story i
want to know about their family how many
grandkids do they have like how is that
they're just
i was waiting for more [ __ ] like i
thought it was gonna be like and then
their cars blew up
and then they lost their home and then
this thing and then a flood happened
and then it's like we don't have that
sign do we
apparently we don't apparently we don't
have that sign anymore
oh i thought it would be worse like yeah
the the flooding the all that [ __ ]
and then they're like you know they went
to the market they're gonna get
the last ribs and then they're like oh
sorry
like they were they didn't get any
toilet paper like when it all happened
and then and they were gonna get some
breakfast at the donut shop but they're
like we're running out of donuts and
they're like what
how can you [ __ ] run out of donuts at
a donut shop we got bagels though
they're like [ __ ] damn why
i know when like a string of bad luck
happens for me personally i'm like well
this must be karma i must have done some
[ __ ] and i was like you feel like you
deserve it yeah
you're like [ __ ] god dude [ __ ] god
i view it either from that lens or the
other lenses
i've been a good person i don't deserve
this damn i'm gonna get some really good
luck to balance this [ __ ] out after
so okay so if someone steals from you
you're like well i'm gonna be a
millionaire then take it [ __ ]
yeah yeah what's the last unlucky thing
that happened
uh a bird [ __ ] on 2020 2020 the whole
year
no i don't know i really don't know i
feel like i get to a
place of anger and then when it starts
when it keeps going
i start laughing me too you ever get
that it was like this is [ __ ] stupid
and then you go oh my god another thing
and then you're like oh it's just funny
now
and then it's like haha yeah why not
right like of course
yes yesterday i was like murphy's law
anything that can go wrong will go wrong
yeah yesterday in the backyard i was
getting ready
to work out i played the music i took my
pre-workout i was chewing gum my [ __ ] i
was getting in the zone i was moving
like my [ __ ]
in place and i walked by one of the
posts
of like the backyard awning thing and i
stubbed my toe
in the middle though that makes a big
difference was it the pinky or the big
toe or the pinky
oh you know you're in the zone you're
like you're trying to be like superman
right like you're like i'm a [ __ ]
superhero i got this [ __ ] workout
and the minute i walked by to hit my toe
but oh [ __ ] so you're going like the
most [ __ ] made
like a [ __ ] form in the world and i'm
like [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] put that there and i look
and it's a cinder block that i put there
i'm like son of a [ __ ]
see it balanced out you put it there and
you you got the
consequence from it i know but then it
became but then i was angry
and i started laughing immediately
because that's pretty funny
good that's good we can all laugh at our
own misery yeah
and that's kind of like the best
medicine though laughing at your own
pain
i like to laugh at other people's pain
that too that's my favorite
reality tv or just listening to drama
from other people that i i don't know
dude i get scared of that too
like i get i get scared of um okay so if
i
see someone fall and it's really funny
and instinctually you're like oh [ __ ]
that was funny i want to laugh
but i try to catch myself and i'm like
no but are you okay cause i'm like
[ __ ] that i don't want to get hurt and
then it ends up coming back to me and
then like everyone's just laughing and
i'm over here like
dying and [ __ ] i'm like well like karma
for laughing at someone that's because
you believe in karma
that's me that that's me i don't believe
that that [ __ ] is connected to me at all
i feel like everything's connected so
not to me i get scared
that's why i don't i don't cut i don't
there's a butterfly effect like it's
gonna
go back and then come back or yeah yeah
i feel like whatever energy you put out
it comes back to you so that's why i do
not criticize or i try my hardest
and i don't think i have i don't
criticize ugly babies like i will not
point it out and be like that's an ugly
baby because i'm like
that's just going to come back but don't
you think you think it you think it and
it's already
in the the energy is already out there
you don't feed into it i didn't i wasn't
like an intention was put out there it
was just like a natural
like thought and then i'm like oh okay
hold on there's no intentions being put
into that thought
yeah i saw it because i if i said that
right and i laugh
[ __ ] ugly ass baby and i get one i
don't see it as punishment
i'm like [ __ ] man my ancestors had some
ugly ass jeans
because that's damn it i guess i'm ugly
too
you take that responsibility and then
you accept yourself you just [ __ ]
accept it man and then you go and then
you gotta be funny
and one in one era though i i just know
that in
one era like maybe 200 years ago i was
fine as [ __ ]
okay i was tall as [ __ ] i was [ __ ]
hygienic as [ __ ]
one in one era that one i think you have
control of
you've got to think about that you you
have genetically you know genetically
have you seen marilyn monroe like some
people be like she was a sex symbol at
the time
i'm like thank god i'm not in that era
you don't find her attractive yeah you
don't find her attractive well i mean
there's some photos of her where she got
double chin and [ __ ] hair all over
her arms and it's a different era it's a
different
it's a different scale right now there's
everyone has hair but have you seen the
chicks from her era compared to her
though
he has arms too look at that you know
all i'm saying is all i'm saying is
girls
now are way prettier so the the basic
because they buy their bodies no
no i actually don't think that those
girls are hot i'm thinking like average
everyday girls today
just daily that they look hotter than
what was the hottest of our grandparents
maybe because you're in this era as well
so it is
it's going with your beauty standard
because you're in this too that's
absolutely what's happening yeah
i don't know about that no but i'm not
agree with joe if you look at george
washington he's [ __ ] ugliest
yeah but that was the standard back then
so he could have been fine as [ __ ]
because everyone else was really [ __ ]
busted
because he had the wooden teeth and [ __ ]
when other people didn't even have teeth
yeah that's what i'm saying isn't that
better is it are we aren't you glad that
we live in such a time
where people of course smell better they
look better
everything and then i look at my
ancestors like
you know what if this was a hundred
years ago i would have been
the hottest [ __ ] in town true
but then you think about your future
generations within your family then
they'd be laughing back at you then
and you probably feel pretty sorry about
yourself yeah i only think of me
in a great position not in a bad
position and who cares you're gonna be
dead by then anyway
hey that's my [ __ ] grandkids fault i
mean i mean that's their problem to deal
with
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
you